um so I'll I'll start hello everybody uh
it's uh nice to uh speak with you today
uh the title of this talk is pathway
based approaches for disease
identification novel approaches and
pitfalls and I would like to recognize
uh some of my co-contributors who
include um Ivan goroff here at Dartmouth
uh hi big the Baller in Germany M ya
young in at UT Health Science Center in
Houston and SAR the car at Cambridge and
SAS prek also
at um in Germany at d uh so um before we
get started I thought I would uh just uh
mention um as an example an application
of a pathway based approach which um was
recently published um and I'm going to
push this uh link out to you uh which um
is a nature paper um it's uh
discussing a uh sort of integration of
multiple uh studies gen and white
Association studies that identified
novel variants and then uh use those
variants to explore Pathways that
influence susceptibility to disease and
subsequently
identified uh compounds that have worked
uh for treating rheumatoid arthritis as
well as uh suggesting new compounds that
may be helpful and so the idea of
pathway based approaches is that when we
perform studies uh such as Gom
Association analyses we identify many
many variants that are relevant dis
disease causation but the integration of
these findings may be complicated and
and and additionally um many variants
that we identify may not reach uh the
stringent levels of significance that we
require um and the pathway based
approaches May provide more information
about uh uh the VAR the variants that
influence disease susceptibility while
also Al integrating the information into
more biologically meaningful um results
so uh going back to the presentation um
I I'll move on to the next slide so in
order to move back since I pushed this
uh out to you you'll have to click on
the tab at the top that that shows the
uh the presentation um so I've uh
develop this um this presentation as a
set of questions um the first question
is what is a gene
pathway and one one definition would be
that it's a set of genes that jointly
coordinate a cellular process um one
example would be the cyto Kinesis
pathway or tricarboxylic cycle um these
uh kinds of pathways are cataloged in
several different resources one of them
is the gene onology
project and that project organized genes
into certain attributes such as the
cellular component molecular function or
biological processes that the uh genes
influence um there's a software uh
program called Amigo that's helpful for
people that would like to uh uh retrieve
data and um this software draws in uh
data from multiple sources such as
unipro which uh provides information
about interactions among genes at the
protein level um and uh when you do
queries from uh Gene onology you can
control what information you will be
retrieving and this slide is showing you
the different aspects of the retrieval
that you can control so that's the nice
thing about uh the Gen genom onology U
uh environment um additional uh
resources for identifying Pathways that
are commonly used includes uh biocarta
which um has user supplied interactions
mostly derived from proteomic studies uh
there's The Keg Koto Encyclopedia of
genes and genomes which uh is manually
curated from the literature and
describes gen Gene interactions so this
is very popular because it's been
carefully uh evaluated for
consistency and um also provides nice
graphical interfaces um there's a couple
of available software programs Ingenuity
uh is available um and provides pathway
information um it's it's maintained on a
central web server so it's updated
regularly by their company um pathway
studio uh also does something similar
but it distributes the pathway out to
the users and so it can be more rapid
computationally for people that are
doing a lot of work sort of online so
here's a typical example of a pathway
diagram from the Kyoto uh resource and
um I'm just showing this as a as an
example you have interactions in my
multiple genes and then you also have um
in sort of circles here uh additional
places where Pathways additional
Pathways interact with this this
particular one so um pathways are not
independent they they form a complex
Network among Pathways and so that's a
little bit of a complexity in the
analysis that we perform um an
additional kind of approach uh is Tex
mining um so this is not really a
pathway based approach but it's a way of
identifying relationships jeans one
example is called Grail and it uses text
mining of published papers to identify
relationships among genes that have been
presented in the
literature um so the advantage of this
is that it's quite automatic and updates
very quickly and it does provide new
insights uh the disadvantage is that
just because a couple of uh genes are
mentioned in a paper does not
necessarily mean that they have
meaningful interactions at the protein
level so um is sort of a useful resource
but um more limited than the other
pathway based approaches I described
previously um so uh now the question is
what is a gene so we expect to include
components of a gene that code for the
protein um most genes have
non-translated components that affect
the tis isue specific expression and so
they are relevant to how the gene
influences a disease development um many
genes have multiple uh transcripts and
some genes like the ugt family include
um many members that have shared Exon so
sometimes the definition of what a gene
is a bit
complicated and that becomes relevant
especially in uh studies uh from g g
Association analysis because we
typically Define a region as being the
gene but um in some cases uh the region
can be multiple different genes and so
there's a lack of uh uniqueness in in
some cases um and many genomic regions
include RNA products and um so our our
definitions are getting broader as we
move forward in time um standard
annotation approaches like geneontology
may not well capture information about
some of these non-coding sequences yet
and many genes are not yet mapped to
pathway so that's a limitation of the
pathway based approach um and how a
pathway approach has been used I I
discussed that briefly in the beginning
um these arise from gene expression
paradigms uh uh usually in the past for
which gene expression eray provide
information about RNA expression levels
um RNA expression panels typically have
about 20,000
transcripts and uh the pathway based
approaches were most popular or are most
popular for Gene enrichment which
evaluates departure of P values from an
expected uniform
distribution um so uh the GSA approach
for expression analysis uses an
enrichment score um in which the
uh the let's say you're studying NG
genes in a in an expression study you
rank order those according to expression
um and uh you would form a set that are
in a pathway and then you identify the
uh the correlations of the expression
patterns with the penina type of in
interest so that's the rjs listed here
so for example that might be correlation
between expression and case control
status um and then one evaluates the
fraction of genes in the pathway
weighted by their correlation against
the uh fraction of genes not in the
pathway and form a statistic um and
elements of this statistic um so s is
the members of the pathway C is the
phenotype and um p is a kind of a um a
waiting uh Criterion when P equals zero
this is a callar smob test and when p is
one then it's waiting by the cor
correlations noriz by the sum of all
correlations and genes so anyway this
provides a way of prioritizing how how
strong the evidence is uh for the
pathway being involved versus um against
evidence for that and so in the initial
paper there's an examp few examples um
the left panel of S1 here uh was looking
at expression comparing uh males and
females and those were uh ex swing teans
so you expect that there would be um
upweighting
um for more uh genes highly expressed
related to um male female differences so
that occurred in S1 S2 sort of a null
and S3 shows sort of complicated um up
weting of a pathway so that that's sort
of the example from expression arrays
and um now we have the problem of how do
Snips relate to a genes so um the usual
approach that we typically apply sets a
window around the coding region of genes
for example a 50 kilobase window um and
then multiple Snips occur within a a
gene um and and we usually use single
nucleotide polymorphisms for the this
analysis um one of the complexities here
is that large genes uh typically include
more uh Snips and uh Snips that affect
gene expression uh May reside either
inside or outside the coating region um
we hope that the 50 kilobase window that
we typically apply uh includes enough of
those Snips but in some cases that may
be problematic and example c um and
closest s to a gene might affect some
other uh nearby genes so that again
that's another
limitation um of this kind of approach
um as we go forward in time we may get
better at identifying uh which uh Snips
are influencing which genes um and so
we're doing uh sort of uh as well as we
can by this uh window approach but it's
a liation at the moment um so how do we
use Snips to represent Pathways so in
the Gen set enrichment approach uh the
way this has been applied is to use the
most significant snip in a in in a gene
as being the one that represents that
Gene um again larger genes have more
Snips and so the P values relate to the
number of snips that were studied and uh
the concern is this might lead to more
positive findings for larger genes one
way to manage this is by a a permutation
procedure um you could also use the sum
of P values to cost Snips and that U
will not cause a problem
of um inflation with larger genes but it
might lose some power of multiple Snips
or unrelated to the disease risk that's
studied and you uh would need to allow
for some kind of correlation among the
Snips um so uh you could also try doing
empirical evaluation there's a nice
software called scan which helps you to
pull up U expression levels of snips
related to genes of interest and so I I
presented that here for you to look at
um so here's the genes and enrichment
the gwas is the semal paper by W all um
they actually applied this approach to
the Department
disease example and they uh Ed the uh
GSA approach I I described earlier um
and applied the most significant sniff
ande this method worked quite well in
this
example um and uh this is sort of
another application to um macular
degeneration again showing that it
worked fairly well in this example um
another kind of approach that you might
take uh because there could be uh many
different uh genes involved in um or or
suggested as playing a role you could U
apply penalization approaches to limit
the number of genes that you consider so
there's this nice paper by Chan at all
um and um as examples um we've also
applied um genom yina pathway approaches
um so my colleagues uh and I developed
an method another set of
methods that manage the correlations
among Snips uh rather than picking the
most significant snip we we use the
combination of all of them and uh the
nice thing about these studies is they
took advantage of multiple data sets um
in rheumatoid arthritis so one could
build a model in one data set and
validated in the next um there's also a
nice paper referred in the last slide by
car all to conary biliary sosis um in
this application there were two
different tests that were developed one
was a linear combination test in which
um the uh P values at each position were
summ together and adjusted for the
correlation among the Snips so that
removes any concern about uh length bias
of the snip uh or the pathway
influencing the uh number of significant
results that one obtains um an
alternative approach is the Quadra
quadratic test in which the P values are
used directly and adjusted for the
correlation among the uh the Snips and
when these methods uh were applied um we
uh in the linear combination test we
obtained a a large number of interesting
Snips many of these were in the h La
region so of course these are um likely
to be correct in ptpn22 which we know is
a gene related to ROR arthritis also
shows up in the top set um when the
quadratic test was used um a large
number of Pathways were identified um
and uh these make some sense uh the uh
several new Pathways were identified by
analyzing these data and um if you
compare the pathways uh between the two
different data sets the welcome trust
and the North American Ruma toid
arthritis Consortium that Rose to the
top um uh same Pathways were identified
individual genes that are included in
the pathway were not necessarily the
same uh so in this example the red uh
Marts are the significant uh genes in
the pathway and um on this slide we show
the results for the welcome trust
finding and the next slide we show for
narra so there were different um
members um but the entire pathway shows
up and so that that's kind of the U
value added on the pathway based
approach is that you uh don't
necessarily have enough information to
pick up all the gene signals in a
pathway but by coordinately
analyzing all those genes you can still
pick up the pathway as playing a
relevant role for disease
causation so uh we I separately applied
these methods in a genomewide
Association study of melan that u i
conducted with my collaborators at MD
Anderson and um additional collaborators
uh in the UK and Australia and uh so
this is the G genomite Association that
stud uh results showing all the
different significant findings across
the genome so we took those results and
applied uh the uh LCT and the quadratic
tests that I described um in a couple of
slides earlier and um the significant
pathway many significant Pathways were
identified by the quadratic tests uh
which I thought was very exciting but on
further evalu ation of these Pathways
noticed that some very lengthy Pathways
were rising to the top and um although
the neuroactive like and receptor
interaction pathway is kind of
interesting um it's not something that I
uh necessarily would have um thought of
as my top hit and um because I was a
little anxious about that we decided to
permute the data so we took the the
cases and control in the original data
set and permuted those swapping the
labels and when we did that um we found
unfortunately a very strong correlation
between the size of the number of genes
in a pathway um and uh the significance
and even the number of snips in a gene
and the significance um this is
something that you really don't want to
occur in a pathway based approach
because um it raises the concern
concerned that um you're finding a false
positive finding someone with the true
positives and um we didn't see that in
LCT application um the original paper
didn't show any uh bias and so um I
think the particular issue here may have
to do with um the r code that we're
using um for this
application um in general I think I'm
just trying to point this uh question
out as a a as something worth evaluating
if you have a length or a pathway bias
in in your results it's it's worth
taking a second look um so this just
shows you sort of the correlation so in
the LCT approach there was no
correlation in the Q T approach in this
application there there was a
correlation um so uh sort of moving
forward in time we've been um working
with our collab ators in Germany uh
they've been driving the development of
logistic kernel machine test approaches
so these approaches um uh first adjust
for covariant so that's what these
regression coefficients beta one two uh
beta M are doing and then there's a a
linear kernel so that's this H component
which um seeks to identify the um set of
variants that um optimally um separate
cases and controls and then there's so
this is a uh not semi- parametric
approach to um identifying um genes and
then uh Snips within genes and then uh
genes within Pathways that U relate to
disease causation and um to perform the
test uh one forms the quadratic form
which turns out to be a sort of
complicated mixture of K Square
variables fortunately um the uh
literature on pathway based uh sorry Kel
based uh methods is welld developed and
and methods for identifying the U the
correct distribution of K squares are
well established so um this method could
be applied um and so uh the the things
that we need in a in a kernel based test
or any pathway based test with Snips is
that there size and variance um and we
correct for the correlation structures
among the Snips um and finally that we
um incorporate the pathway structure so
U to do this um zasia freack and and
hial are developed size invariant
multiplicative and distance kernels um
and uh the kernel um includes a this
ukian distance measure it corrects for
the number of genes in a
pathway um it groups the Snips uh with
regard to their Gene me membership and
then it corrects for the number of
effective Snips in the uh Team um by
identifying the number of effective
tests that were uh conducted um and then
um one needs to construct a network
based kernel so first that's done by m
Snips to genes and then um one also Maps
the genes to the U Pathways and adjust
for the uh for the correlations among
the genes within the pathway um and so
uh in this
application uh a similar uh analysis was
conducted of the North American rheumat
toy darts rius Consortium data and um uh
three different methods were applied a
linear kernel machine test with a linear
kernel Al one with a network based
kernel and uh then one using G set
enrichment and um we we're a little we
felt that the uh network based kernel
provided the most succinct U uh sort of
characterization of the pathways that
were identified and in this uh figure um
I'm giving you the two references
for this method um so and some of the
top Pathways from analysis include type
1 diabetes systemic lupus rheumatoid
arthritis which we expect um viral
myocarditis and the fagm which is
probably a new uh Network for rator
arthritis so there there were some novel
findings from this analysis
um so uh future directions uh would
evaluate behav
um evaluating the behavior more
completely um comparing this linear
kernel machine test to some other
methods um in integrating teen and
pathway based approaches uh from snip T
studies um with let's say the cancer
genome Atlas so one of the sort of um
challenges that we have in the cancer
World um is that we have uh some very
large and excellent studies being
conducted to to identify genetic
susceptibility for cancer and then we
have a whole separate set of analyses
being conducted uh to explore the
changes that occur in the sematic uh
tissues and these two uh sort of
approaches aren't very well integrated
so if we could further integrate those
that that would be a value added um and
then further exploration of application
of methods using um some new approach is
there's a gcpa approach which um can be
used uh for genomewide Association
studies to um first identify the most
significant Snips in a region uh then
remove any additional Snips that are
being identified because they're in dis
equilibrium with the most significant
snip so condition on the most
significant snip then identify all the
additional Snips that remain after that
conditioning that that will result in a
more parsimonious uh view of those Snips
that are relevant for uh the
relationship of U of genes to disease
causation and uh trim the number of
genes that are being nominated for
inclusion in in the pathway analysis and
and we we've done some work on this kind
of approach
um finding that um it it does certainly
lead to a much reduced number of markers
to U and genes to consider in the
pathway studies so I think I will stop
at that point I think I'm sort of a
little uh in good shape here for time
and um I will ask questions um not sure
I see any but um let me click on my
button so I don't have any question
questions right now um if there are any
I will answer them but um um otherwise I
will
just be finished I'll wait a second or
two
um I want to thank my uh collaborators
for their
input and um uh this is a very
interesting area uh that's continuing to
develop um there are
massive amounts of genom mod Association
studies that have been very informative
and uh being able to translate these
into clinically meaningful applications
um is sort of our goal I I would like to
point out that I saw very uh interesting
U
uh let's
see let me just say I I saw a very
interesting uh recent uh uh result that
U that
a novel therapy for alishia Arata was
developed
from observations that the Jack stat
Pathways involved in alipa Arata so um
that led to application of drugs that
Target that pathway and um so uh there
there these seem to be novel approaches
that are being um um for clinical use uh
from uh genome wide study so I see that
says only three last slid list in the
content we change that yeah I will
change that I understand
question so I guess that's all the
all I guess that's of my
presentation
for